hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game that happened yesterday
in the Pro chess League it is a German
Grandmaster or rather German woman
Grandmaster Josefina heinemann versus
Hikaru Nakamura it's uh it's quite a
brutal game from the opening church that
Hikaru goes for to the devastating
attack that he unleashes and then uh the
game is settled by uh by uh one piece
I'm not gonna say which piece because
it's gonna spoil the pause the video
moment but what a magnificent piece it
is now let's check out the game uh
Josefina has the white pieces and she
opens with Ponte E4 we have D6 D4 and
Hikaru goes for F5 he shifts over to the
Dodge defense the Stanton ball of
Defense uh we have e captures an F5
Bishop captures and now Bishop to D3
challenging hikaru's Bishop on F5 Queen
to D7 defending and now Knight to F3
Josefina continues development Knight to
F6 and now she trades on F5 Bishop
captures Queen captures and she just
castles the safety we have Knights to
see sexy going after the D4 Pawn C3 and
now Pawn to E5 there is one game where
castles was played but here Hikaru plays
E5 and it is now as of move 8 that we
have a completely new game and there are
two ways to to go about this position
one is to just grab more space in the
center with D5 let's say d597 C4 and
then you maybe look for some chances on
the queen side or the other one what
Josefina chose and that is the captures
on E5 opening up the center makes sense
hikaru's King is still in the center of
the board D captures an E5 and now Rook
to E1 putting pressure on that E5 pawn
bishop to D6 now preparing the castle
Queen side and pawn to H3 taking away
the G4 Square from Black's pieces uh
Hikaru castles Queen side now the queen
should move as well if this bishop move
somewhere uh it could be could be very
dangerous for the moment it doesn't have
all that many great squares but still
she moves the queen to E2 maybe Shifting
the Knight H4 chasing away the queen
maybe if you could get your queen to
this diagonal also could be playable but
she goes Queen to 8 q and this he gives
Hikaru an excellent opportunity to
advance his Pawn to E4 which opens up
this diagonal and frees up the E5 Square
for his Knight and okay Knight to H2 and
now Knight to E5 and Hikaru can be
extremely happy with his position with
Bishop to E3 and now the Knight even
comes to D3 putting pressure on the rook
and putting constant pressure on that F2
Pawn so Rook the D1 getting the Rook out
of Harm's Way and now Pawn to H5 Hikaru
is now ready to push G5 G4 and bust open
the white King's position uh she has to
figure out how to continue the game how
to develop the pieces she goes Knight to
A3 now she wants to shift the Knight to
C2 maybe to D4 and the cleanest way to
play this would be to just eliminate
this uh Knight which looks kind of odd
because you give up the very strong
Bishop here and you give why the
semi-open B file but you will get your
Rook to G6 attack the white king and
everything will be fine however he
decided to go for G5 and this makes the
game a lot more interesting now the
Knight comes to C4 attacks the bishop on
D6 and Hikaru trades Bishop captures on
H2 King captures an H2 and the G4 ready
to open up the position she prevents it
she plays Pawn to H4 and now Knight to
D5 getting the other Knight into the
action King back to G1 helping out with
the defense of the F2 pawn and now he
car played Pawn to A6 which is uh which
is rather weird uh I have no idea what
it does but okay it gives the king some
breeding room maybe if you if you are
forced here and maybe takes away the B5
Square from some future white pieces but
I have no idea maybe he just wants to
save the A7 Pawn uh I I don't know the
idea behind the move but uh putting more
pressure on the f file would be the way
to go but Hikaru played A6 and now Rook
to D2 adds another Defender to df2 pawn
prepares to double up on the D file Rook
H the G8 now he car wants to play G3 and
now Rook a to D1 and Hikaru goes for it
pawn to G3 now the only way to survive
this is to play F3 you have to keep the
G file closed so Pawn to F3 and now
again Hikaru should put the Rook on E8
put pressure on that Queen on E2 and
then it doesn't matter you will either
capture on F3 or if or if white captures
then you already have a rook and E8 will
be will be very good for you he however
plays Queen to F6 he rushes it a little
bit he wants to play Queen captures on
each four and then Queen to H2 check
which will probably result in a very
quick Checkmate but he also allows the
bishop to G5 now what's the point here
he car wants to sacrifice The Exchange
and then just go for the white king
hence the quote above the board Bishop
to G5 and he goes for it Rook captures
on G5 H characters and now Queen
captures again Queen H4 Queen to H2 is
coming but she finds Queen captures an
E4 it's the only move that keeps her in
the game and uh remarkably she is now in
a much better position and here after
Queen captures uh on e4 we have Knight
three to F4 Hikaru blocks the Queen's
reach of the H4 Square again he wants to
play Queen H4 Queen to H2 and Hikaru is
uh very in in a very very good position
here however if she finds one move that
the one that we've discussed at the
beginning of the video uh Hikaru is just
dead lost here so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Josefina uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
beautiful beautiful move and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Knight to E3 the only move that
saves the game and now this spectacular
Steed is coming to F1 and from F1 the
Knight will be covering the H2 square
and without uh the queen having access
to that H2 Square Hikaru has no attack
of course it's impossible to trade here
because then just throw capture 78 wins
the game and there is no move for Hikaru
here he still continues Queen H4 but now
just Knight to F1 and look at this
annoying Knight here just uh uh uh I
believe completely uh annoying Hikaru
here there's nothing more to be done
here uh he plays C6 now okay the the
Knight is um uh really well placed on D5
but of course C4 is coming she plays
Pawn to C4 and now Hikaru has to start
giving up material he tries Rook to D7
he wants to play rookie seven and maybe
get something with the Knight to E2
check but the material material is just
material so C captures on D5 Rook to E7
attacks the queen queen F5 check King to
B8 and now D captures on C6 we ignite
the E2 with check the white King has no
squares but uh she will of course just
give up The Rook for the sniper captures
on E2 Rook captures and now Queen to f8
with check and it doesn't matter where
Hikaru goes with the King if he goes to
A7 it's just a very quick Checkmate
Queen C5 checking be it and now Queen B6
uh Checkmate will be on on B7 or even
just Rook to d8 will be enough to win
the game so after this check Hikaru
forced to bring his King into the center
of the board King C7 now Queen to D6
with check King to B6 and pawn to C7 the
other Queen is now coming into the game
King the A7 she played uh C8 Queen and
it was in this position on move 37 that
Hikaru Nakamura resigned to the game and
a spectacular victory for the much lower
rated player Josefina heinemann who
takes uh takes down the one and only
Hikaru Nakamura and even though you are
very close to the white king this Pawn
here is beautiful The Rook is
beautifully placed the Queens very
nicely placed this night just prevents
anything and uh okay if you guys are
wondering why didn't she bring a knight
into the game because it might be cooler
uh oh yeah okay it could be cooler but
after King Tei there's just no no
follow-up there's no cool Checkmate
there's no smother Mater there's no
nothing here and you're gonna uh spend
even more time winning this game than
you would by bringing a queen into the
game so in this particular position uh
bringing a queen and not going for the
cool option uh definitely was the way to
go but here even if Hikaru tries to give
up The Rook there's just no follow-up
the Knight is so spectacular here and
this is one of the greatest pieces that
we've seen on the channel uh in in a
while so a bit a big round of applause
for this night if you will so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by Josefina heinemann
taking down a true legend of the Arena
that is Nakamura I would like to thank
cities for trade Ricky black castor
Johnson Robert Trenton and Rodney bar
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot I really appreciate it as usual
you can check to all my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the protest League uh and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day